[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اشتعال القتال شرقي
اوكرانيا وقصف متبادل في محيط القوات
الاوكرانيه تعلن احراز تقدم جنوبي المدينه
وقبيله قمه المقبله في ليتوانيا
بالحاق ضرر ممنهج بمحطه زابوريا النوويه
وتطالب الحلف بمناقشه القضيه ازمه هجره
غير مسبوقه تواجهها تونس وفاه طالب لجوء
وفقدان ما لا يقل عن عشره بعد غرق قارب
قباله سواحل صفاقس السلطات التونسيه فيما
وصفتها بالاكاذيب بشان معاملتها لا
انسانيه للمهاجرين الافارقه وليبيا تطالب
تونس بابعاد المهاجرين عن حدودها لاسباب
امنيه اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع جنوبيه الخرطوم وغربها
الجيش ينفي استهداف مدنيين بغارات على ام
درمان ويتهم الدعم بتضليل الراي العام
ومصدر دبلوماسي افريقي ليكشف عن مشاركه
ممثلين عن طرفي الازمه في اجتماع الايجاد
الاثنين في اديس ابابا المنتخب المغربي
المستضيف يتوج بلقب النسخه الرابعه من كاس
افريقيا تحت 23 عاما بفوزه على نظيره
المصري بهدفين لواحد بعد تمديد المواجهه
لشوطين اضافيين على ملعب الامير مولاي عبد
الله في مدينه الرباط الى اللقاء